جديد في هضمي التوترات التي شهدتها
الاراضي الفلسطينيه واسرائيل في الايام
القليله الماضيه جاءت زياره وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه الى الشرق الاوسط حامله معها
ملفات عديده على راسها ايجاد حلول لخفض
هذه التوترات بلانكن اكد على دوره اتخذ
اجراءات سريعه وفوريه لتخفيف حده التوتر
بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين وقال ان
واشنطن تعارض اي خطوات تقوض حل الدولتين
كهدم البيوت وانشاء المستوطنه
الولايات المتحده عازمه على العمل مع
الشركائها لتعزيز بيئه اكثر استقرارا
وايجاد حلول الوسطى للخروج من دوامه العنف
واستثناء في محادثه السلام بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين وطلبنا كافه
الاطراف بخفض التصعيد
المؤتمر الصحفي من ان الولايات المتحده لن
تقبل باي خطوه احاديه قد تجعل من مساله حل
الدولتين امرا اعتدى مما هي الان
كلا واضحين ومتصقين في قناعتنا بانه لا
ينبغي لاي من الطرفين اتخاذ اي اجراءات
احاديه الجانب الان من المحتمل ان تصب
الزيت على النار على مدى فتره طويله من
الزمن والتي من شانها ان تاخذ حل الدولتين
الى ابعد مما هو عليه اليوم
اما الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس فحمل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه مسؤوليه التصعيد في
الفتره الاخيره لعدم التزامها بحل
الدولتين مشددا على ان الوقف الكامل
للاعمال الاسرائيليه الاحاديه الجانب هو
المدخل الاساسي لعوده الافق السياسي
ونؤكد لكم لان ما يحدث هذه الايام
تتحمل مسؤوليته الحكومه الاسرائيليه
في سبب ممارساتها التي تقود حل الدولتين
وتخالف الاتفاقات الواقعه
وبسبب عدم بذل الجهود الدوليه
[موسيقى]
منظومه في الاستيطان
وعدم الاعتراف بالدور الفلسطينيه